what's up guys so we were just about to
shoot our superman and lois episode 2
reaction and then zack snyder's justice
league went ahead and released the
titles for all their chapters
in the four-hour movie that we're going
to be getting right around
the corner first things first we're
going to be like reacting to it and
breaking it down in the moment because
we haven't seen them yet so i want to
throw it out there while we're
theorizing on the spot
what i want you guys to do go to the
comment boxes and leave down your
breakdown
for whatever you think these chapters
all are what the structure of it will be
odds are there's going to be a few of
you who are going to have a much better
graston idea than what we got but we're
going to do our best while we're here
secondly i gotta admit something
for some reason my mind was telling me
for the longest time that i had seen the
batman v superman ultimate edition
it was the weekend and then i realized
wait a minute i don't think i've
actually seen this that's right
a couple years ago i intended to see it
i couldn't get access to it for some
reason at the time so what i did was i
watched like all the deleted scenes on
youtube and just filled in the blank
since i had seen the theatrical cut
three times and my mind just went yeah
this one's way better this one's way
better this is enough yeah
and then i watched it the other day all
three hours from beginning to end
i realized whoa there's like little
things
throughout there's things throughout
from beginning to end that are not in
the theatrical cut and for some reason
my mind was telling me that i'd already
seen this when i hadn't and
wow i might have to change my dcu
ranking list i have not shut up about
this you could ask john yeah
for days i've just been talking about my
video this movie is so good to bring it
so good i'm more excited for zack
snyder's justice league more than ever
and considering that those three hours
are easy to sit through four hours of an
ensemble
imagine it'll be a blast i don't know
why i'm putting on headphones havoc
let's get into it
all right going to social media all
right here we go here we go
part one don't count on it batman
okay that's pretty self-explanatory i
mean that's where batman is trying to
bring together the justice league
bring the team together he's having a
hard time bringing the team together you
know like
aquaman apprehensive hesitant cyborg
has it i mean i feel like the only one
who'll be on board will be
flash and then wonder woman will be
helping him
out kind of like the super super duper
condensed version of what we got in
justice league
yeah that makes sense all right that's
why did you say that name it's a decent
part one
all right what's part two part two is
the age of heroes all right so i'm
assuming the team starts coming together
right engineering is coming back they're
coming together i love that it's divided
into chapters a that's going to make our
life a lot easier if we are able to
do a proper reaction to this and put it
up on youtube
we have no idea how to like how would we
divide this this makes it a lot easier
to
figure out how to divide this and i got
to imagine that this may also give us a
clue as to what the plan would have been
had they gone with the mini series route
you know you could probably divide it up
by these chapters and watch
it over six nights if you want to well i
heard there was like legality and
payment issues that you run into
when you pay someone to star in a series
of the paid them per episode
versus paying them for one movie yeah
and this is also more of zack snyder's
original vision this is the way
i'd want to see it especially after
watching the ultimate edition of bvs now
but the fact that it is a four hour
movie
having these parts helps it easier for
people to know okay we can take a break
right now if we need to
yeah and part three who beloved mother
beloved son okay
okay i got his the mother well i mean
yes we're dealing with mother boxes and
also you got uh
steppenwolf with his mother in the box
yeah
so you have that one thing that i think
especially from we're watching bvs was
that
what zack snyder likes to do is like do
parallel stories yeah
so i think this could have several
meetings perhaps clark is resurrected at
this point
and he has this reunion with his mom we
did see
cyborg in the trailer where he's digging
through the graveyard
it looks like there'll be some visions
or dreams something like that where
he'll you might see his mom here and
there i feel like this chapter in
particular
would have a real parallel type of
storytelling going on yeah i can see
this kind of being the point at which
the movie slows down a little bit or
maybe diverts focus more toward the
personal side of both the motivations of
everybody on the league but also it
could be steppenwolf because
you know the mother boxes and in a way
he is sort of the chosen
one come to deliver you know darkseid's
vision at this stage in the games
yeah all right par four change machine
i mean they keep saying cyborg's the
heart of the story yeah and that
this is gonna be like in a lot of ways
his movie and this is zack snyder
himself you know saying he's the heart
of this film
and i think he was asked recently like
what is it he's really
excited for people to see and i think he
said it was cyborg's journey it's the
same change machine
i feel like that would be the most
obvious thing to hone in on
well yeah and given again if we're
following this point in a very large
story it could also be the changing
point at which the team itself
sort of comes together and maybe cyborg
has a big
part in that yes being the heart of the
movie and the team and all that
all right then part five let's see here
all the king's horses
i mean i venture to say that this is
dealing with the apocalypse
it's dealing with uh i venture to say
this is dealing with
the apocalypse moments here because you
know we got kind of some flock for this
when we said that it's when batman is
with joker that it's like a dream
vision sequence because we were going
off with zack snyder's quote when he
said that he specifically
said that it was like a vision yeah
right even batman and the trailer says i
had a dream almost like a premonition
kind of like a double layer because the
idea is that if they do not succeed they
will enter
into the apocalypse they will enter into
the thing that batman has
been seeing where flash came from to
talk to to bruce and bvs saying
you know it's lois am i too early i feel
like this would be a dedicated section
to that
i don't think it would just be the big
finale that we're all waiting for
it might be in reference to the big
finale with all the pair demons or the
bat tank shows up and all that
jazz the part where you know joss whedon
turned it all to red
so it could be that but i feel like with
the fact of how zack snyder often likes
to use
christianity metaphors dealing with the
apocalypse
i would assume that that's more of what
we'll be getting more of the focus here
and maybe that's the jared leto sequence
too
yeah for sure
all right six this is something darker
than i don't know i mean how dark have
we been up until this point anybody know
you got like a fun one with part one
that's almost like tarantino-esque don't
count on it batman
then they sound like chapters out of a
book you know as they keep going
like biblical and epic and then
something darker yeah yeah yeah and
especially on the heels the last one
that has like
connotations you could follow through to
like they couldn't put the situation
back together again
this is also making me think like okay
so we're gonna have a dour ending on
this movie and they've said it's got a
cliffhanger it's not gonna just wrap up
so i'm like is this gonna be
a super dark cliffhanger movie that
we're not
maybe gonna ever see a conclusion for
well i mean that's the whole point of
the public negotiation but
it could be dealing specifically with
the cliffhanger
because the original cliffhanger was
supposed to be us anticipating dark side
showing up i forget the
full details and parts of me are okay
with forgetting some of the details
i remember like yeah steppenwolf loses
and then we're supposed to see dark side
again at the end and then
so it's really teasing that we're going
to be getting dark side and then i
believe part two of justice league was
supposed to deal with
going to the apocalypse my memory is a
little foggy on it
and i'm okay with that considering the
fact that we're about to get the movie
but i guess i mean i i feel like a whole
chapter dedicated to just the
cliffhanger
sounds kind of weird yeah 10 minute chat
partner yeah
i don't know i mean i guess there would
have to be if you look at like a season
of a show or anything like that or
anything that's ongoing i mean you do
have to do a certain amount of
concluding anyway so
maybe it's also hinting that where our
characters come to rest
at the end of this one story is probably
not a very happy place for them which
again
you know is is kind of a funky thing to
to think about if this could be the last
one
it's like i don't want to leave
everybody in a place where i'm like i'm
hurting for all these people as the
credits roll but
it could be i mean there's a lot of
trouble coming there yeah
oh [ __ ] all right snyder cut chapters
i'm excited for this movie more excited
than ever i really am i mean we're
visiting his
films going to that article that he did
talking about like his daughter autumn
all that combined with the hype and the
build-up and just the wanting this movie
for so long
i can't wait i'm very much excited for
it all right guys leave your thoughts
down below what you think this all
means very curious to know subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
uh last but not least
wanted to shout out a person named fox
who's been incredible to our channel
especially
as of late and uh considering the fact
that zack snyder himself
gets involved in a lot of charities held
fundraising and getting this movie
off the ground a lot of it has gone
towards charities and fox wants to shout
out a very specific charity as well
this one is called snow leopard.org and
i'll just read fox's words the best way
to put it
the snow leopard truss conserves land
that is the snow leopard's habitat
works with local farmers to incentivize
them to not shoot snow leopards
provides financial assistance because
losing your livestock is a big deal when
you live in poverty provides education
on more careful hurting practices
provides vaccinations for livestock so
they can stay healthy
works to increase the snow leopard's
natural prey takes action to eliminate
approaching and
much more yeah i think this is a damn
good charity
and uh you know what fox i'll be uh
contributing to this charity for my
monthly charity
i kind of hop around charities and this
this will be the charity i hop around to
this month thank you so much for
mentioning this as an animal lover
myself someone who
specifically stopped eating meat just
because of my love for animals i really
appreciate you wanting to shout this out
i appreciate your pledge too that
pleasure this charity maybe
[Music]